welcome back to you honest trailer
commentaries it's good to be back guys
we're talking down to quest
no inside jokes on the show we haven't
done this one in a while we didn't do
one for the honest teaser because for
Galaxy Quest on time because we went to
see Star Wars that day in stabbed yeah
so here's your better late than never
behind the scenes look at our Galaxy
Quest on trailer
bit of the writing process some cut
jokes do we have any deleted scenes I
don't think we do we do we have a minute
of wow look at that and this is I think
the only video on the screen junkies or
Phantom entertainment channel where you
can see us talk about the movie Galaxy
Quest yes our only Galaxy Quest related
project definitely so let's each go to
circle and talk about why Galaxy Quest
is so good Joe yes because it's it's a
weird perfect alchemy of satire and love
letter and adventure story and meta
thing yeah it all just melts together
and works absolutely perfectly and as we
know from never surrender a Galaxy Quest
documentary on I blown up the charts by
the way yeah it's one of the beautiful
things where it's like it shouldn't have
worked and a number of times should have
fallen apart but did not you know much
like things like a new hope and stuff
like that where it's they're a horrible
mess and somehow the alchemy and magic
of film makes them perfectly you talk
about never surrender at Galaxy Quest
documentary vailable now on itunes i am
okay I like this film a lot I think it's
the second best Star Trek movie I don't
like Star Trek nor do I like their
movies but I do think the number one
best being that weird episode of black
mirror where Landry does bad stuff in
the computer
or heated Star Trek stuff yes bad Star
Trek stuff so by the way Dan just
wherever he is his heart just like yeah
I know I know
where's dad by the way but then yeah I'm
glad he's not here to hear you before
the holidays we're a little loopy and
checked out it's cuz we're already
thinking about a vacation it's because
we've done 20 episodes of television
television in the last like week fair
enough because so you get all that
content you want a lot of configuration
you're getting even some content out for
Santa all your content holds be filled
but yeah but yes Star Trek what I like
about this is not the Star Trek parody
and ripping on Star Trek like it's
ripping on actors that I will always go
something because actors think they're
they can do the thing they like lose
that that border between their roles and
reality like when Mark Wahlberg said
he'd stop 9/11 I think it's fine it's
just a burger his mom's not gonna be
there like they make you think you were
to go and you're gonna give his mom his
mom's not their daddy might be available
yeah we need to stick it to method
actors a little more often yeah I mean
that's my favorite genre of news story
it's there was a my favorites are at the
Wahlberg one there's one other that I
can't remember but also when Angelina
Jolie offered herself as like a honey
trap to catch Kony s remember that one
[Music]
services to like the UN or something
where she was like to like get me in a
room with Kony and then I'll do her
hissed
I love actors something about Whitney
Houston Osama bin Laden I'm not gonna do
don't get very right before vacation
Galaxy Quest I do it is one of my
favorite films again I also I enjoy what
it says about fandom and the power of
being a fan fandom small F then you know
the I thought that that part was amazing
I do like that that guy makes out with a
squid or whatever yeah
but no I genuinely do really love this
movie I think they're great performance
is Tim Allen I can usually take relieve
he is fantastic in this yes good yes is
like his best maknae and people were
bringing up Toy Story like that's
different you know Pixar's doing a lot
of the lifting yeah he doesn't have to
make them it's fine it's fine it's fine
let's watch the trailer for Galaxy Quest
yeah
in the universe full of crappy Star Trek
movies what justice Connie decades had
nothing to do with Star Trek but also
everything to pop in his shirt off for
this heck yeah he did yeah that shirt
off Tim yes oiling up for the day yeah
this is like a pre Marvel like you got
to get ripped because there's no way he
was yeah absolute meant he married his
trainer he did on this movie on this
movie yeah well yeah that didn't make
the documentary deleted scene in the
dock okay
yeah yeah he deleted he married is a
Meredith trainer she got him them abs
and he he put a ring on it
Oh some dudes like a dumb I gotta stop
[Laughter]
I've been talking all day
alright unpause
that looks like fun Galaxy Quest sudha
for a big-budget sci-fi met a comedy
about niche fandom in the 90s wow it's
like they were trying to lose money
positive why does why does everyone
everyone being like the people at this
table love sci-fi comedy but nobody
likes sci-fi company in terms of like
buying it or like doing well in theaters
I think don't you get it I think so many
of them have been stuff where it feels
like it's for kids
yeah and a lot of I've talked about this
before my parents love sci-fi my parents
are like I can't remember the
character's name and and party hard they
like hard sci-fi and maybe hard pretty
damn I'm pretty - yes party hard is an
Andrew wks basically they they don't
like they they like their comedy is one
thing and they like their hard sci-fi
isn't they don't mix their foods yeah I
don't know it so it's a hard nut to
crack right because I think it's almost
like regular sci-fi as a genre you know
like a lot of people aren't gonna like
really heady like Nolan's stuff and a
lot of sci-fi comedy is its own thing
like Douglas Adams is obtuse as hell man
like it's just because so much of it is
in you know the description in the
writing it's so hard to adapt so it's
either like are you gonna go there or
are you gonna go like Paul I don't know
if that was a good movie or not I never
I never saw palming Seth Rogen was like
a little alien that like
I'm assuming I never saw it example is
the world should never be a day yeah
that'd be tough yeah I would watch it
though I would watch it yeah I like it
yeah anyways let's keep going it's
destroyed sci-fi - calm which one Terry
Pratchett books oh they're in there
silly all right keep gone the satire of
old school track spot-on portrayal of
fan culture and hilarious character
driven comedy that morphs into an honest
to goodness action flick and ends with
the film's actors playing the show's
actors playing the crew of a starship
acting out the show in reality in front
of actors playing fans of the fake show
who pretend that it's real except that
it is real and is this movie genius or
did I just smoke whatever Tony Shalhoub
is on every scene is he supposed to be
on xanax like I couldn't figure out I
think so what happened is like what's
you haven't you ever take on his
character right I'm a real Shalhoub ooh
yes
I basically it was like it was just a
very it was like four or five lines in
the script and they were just like Tony
Shalhoub can like really like put a lot
of physical comedy choices into this
very otherwise under written right thing
and then I think as they just started to
improvise more and more onset it
probably just turned into a lot more of
that like there's some commentary that I
think got lost because he's playing a
white guy playing an Asian guy in on the
show yeah he lost that fight yeah where
he was like I don't my name to be Quan
and they were like no that's the bit
right where it's like we're trying to
point out that's not a good thing but
then I bat got lost somewhere in the
probably just pull the rug out from
under yeah and there's talk about
anxiety too and I can't tell if that is
supposed to be a I am so high on the pot
joke I'm anxious or it's supposed to be
a I have to take pills because I'm
anxious yeah I can't either way my whole
era
absolutely hrus tony shalhoub or paul
giamatti who's hotter Oh
Shalu Shalu okay yeah yeah yeah sure
Lube wears a suit better yeah he carries
a briefcase better he added a hot hotter
see I'm a Giamatti man through and
through right oh yeah what's that you
off John Adams I'm going in Rico
Veronica Mars baby dub TV actors get
mistaken for their characters on an old
Syfy show their egos and incompetence
could doom an entire civilization and
when your movie needs a bumbling
washed-up TV actor with a massive ego
you called Tim Allen who wouldn't last
10 seconds in the hashtag make to era
amidst the strange planet is filling my
head with such thoughts but Allen's
paused I did think the like almost I
love you moment that those two had at
the end was a moment of badness yeah she
does not love you too mal know that he
barely tolerates you yeah that seemed
that C needed to be buttoned with her
being like that's never gonna be a thing
you were number one in the Call Sheet
and you're gross
yeah because that's what she that's how
their relationship starts is like it was
a lot cuter when I didn't know who you
were at the beginning of the movie yeah
everyone needs to arc not every
relationship needs dark and I think even
look I know they all collectively saved
the thing together he's not the only
hero so I don't think it's one of those
things was like you saved the world and
now I want to put my tongue down your
throat I don't know I've been a lot of
bad dates recently and I can't think of
any of them that I would like be like oh
you saved the world
now I'm yours how many of them ended
with someone saving that way not yet but
the sweet potato fries and that you know
global warming now Ashton Kutcher us to
go back in time baby
possibly only executive active isn't
moved by the rest of the great cast a
Sigourney Weaver plays against her type
of the strong female lead to play to
Mellon supported by a wetsuit Sam
Rockwell or faked films only fake
plastic honored and the late great Alan
Rickman who walks the razor's edge
well talk about Alan Rickman in a second
but also the choices that Sam Rockwell
is making this movie like he just made
this decision to be the only one who's
like Semite turned on or really into
this alien torture video that the rest
of them are watching character that they
never explore take this oh oh sorry the
the boob reaction needs some context I
realized that that was creepy without I
think in my head I've always just
assumed oh they put a ton of makeup on
her and like pushed her boobs up with
like a machine and anti-gravity bra I
was the early 2000 it was literally they
put of I guess I'd never considered in
the documentary they're like yeah we
just strapped like a fake torso to her
body and I just never considered the
idea of someone approaching Sigourney
Weaver and being like so creepy put on
this well talking to Sigourney in the
documentary she's like I was so excited
to do this to me by somebody that's the
exact opposite of the characters they've
been the past and that she loved it I
would just be very nervous to be like
Hello Sigourney Weaver claimed actress
here's your fake torso yeah yeah sure
yeah anyway yeah she's great mm-hmm
let's keep going we're back her full of
contempt for Tim Allen and being an
actor full of contempt for Tim Allen
dripping with collection of talent did
you note whites in it the crew even has
the Mythbusters for all we know that's
Destiny's Child you don't know the
killer all oh no
so good collection of talent
yes note White's in it the crew even has
the Mythbusters raw we know that's
Destiny's Child scare in all attitude
that nailed the rise of fan culture back
when the internet looked like this that
websites to love by the way that
absolutely nails are obsessive
cataloging of pointless details is the
fact that most hardcore fans mistake
fiction for reality we programmed the
food synthesizer for each of you based
on the regional menu as your birthplace
and the insight that a fans real fantasy
isn't going on an adventure it's finding
out that all the time you spend watching
TV wasn't a colossal waste of time it's
all real the best part of anything they
couldn't predict is how much money you
could make off nerds these days if
Galaxy Quest was real they'd have a CBS
all access show and omen watches and a
crossover episode with the Orville well
yeah puzzle I'm shocked that there isn't
more Galaxy Quest stuff yeah there was a
comic book great there's gonna be a name
is on prime show there was going to be
yeah with the nut Paul Tompkins but Paul
Scheer things because ribbon passed that
they didn't do it
I think okay because everyone was dead
they were all on board right but even
then they could do it with because it's
so meta they could like do something
more like they recast rickman yeah then
you have a guy who's like look I'm not
happy about this
yeah like I I need to pay rent yeah oh
you know maybe now that the docs doing
good okay that's right we're out there
we're legion pain right pay us her first
then me Benja then me again we're thing
Oh Star Trek or Galaxy Quest so kick
back and enjoy a truly underrated film
for at least under viewed because this
is a movie with something for everyone
they got marketed like a dumb screwball
comedy I did not see this movie when it
came out in theaters because and they
made it look dumb I mean it looks so
generic and stupid like the jokes were
all like we share like oh you can't
drive the spaceship I think they could
have gotten more mileage with like a big
audience if they leaned on actors being
self-important rather than like space
hijinks yeah I think they were trying to
market to kids and like kids don't care
about Star Trek like like an
eight-year-old especially back then like
they don't care yeah honestly if I was
gonna market it as like a comedy I will
I would have opened the trailer with did
you like space balls right I mean it's
not at all but it's also not the what
was in the trailer that they released so
and I think I've said this before I saw
space balls before I stopped me too
I mean we were both born post Star Wars
thing we're of an age
yeah we're of a certain age Spaceballs
is everything you need from Star Wars
another fluff
I'll kill it no Philip [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they're not just acting like heroes but
anyone who sees it loves it
especially the people in George we've
all gone on record as saying one of our
favorite Trek films is Galaxy Quest see
now
we wrote this before Raisa Skywalker
came out I'm so glad that people hate
that because that makes this joke work
as well so that's my silver lining well
done yeah we knew but then Watchmen was
great so it kind of okay so that's
Lindelof yeah isn't that weird that like
the two guys from lost like diverged in
a yellow wood and better stuff I think
that's the poem and then there was one
set of footprints yeah that Jesus was
carrying lost yeah yeah that's how you
Jesus lost his Old Testament like to do
leftovers and then watch man I think we
know where the good stuff is coming from
mm-hmm but someone described a sequel
trilogy to the Book of Mormon yeah in
the one of the reviews for rise of
Skywalker they call Jade the most
consistent be student in Hollywood hey
[Laughter]
too much attention either way bees are
fine but it's so true and why you still
don't give the best stuff to the beat
kid but well they're good when you want
when you want safe you give it to
because it's not gonna do anything too
crazy when you wanna be movie movie
movie yeah so people will see it know
sealless stars yeah okay
starring to infinity and be Amin never
give up never surrender now on sale and
I says yep no joke here just a hardcore
thank you to Alan Rickman you have the
marvelous mr. monk
hi I'm a nerd and that's a penny isn't
as committed comic-con start pause one
of the things that didn't ring true in
this movie is that somebody would I
guess it was true in 98 or whatever but
that somebody would go to a comic-con to
make fun of the Nerds like ya know back
then would come you could go to like a
small comic-con like that that's like 15
bucks yeah they totally yeah my dad my
dad took me to like the Louisville
sci-fi con when I was in Middle School
yeah which sidebar he got really before
I knew what Mortal Kombat movie was
coming and he saw a Mortal Kombat movie
poster and was like that's the coolest
poster ever do you like one little
combat and I was like that really he was
like we're buying this for you hell yeah
but we like came out of the pod and
literally the first thing I still
remember this walking out of the con the
very first thing that happened was a guy
was just on for tractors just like yeah
they were out there at the time yeah
look at me growing up in my safe space I
went to San Diego comic-con Chuck 94 got
a paga my face on it
no one believed me excited that POG the
ultimate Park let's finish that slammin
good nine
[Music]
that's not what she said yeah okay it's
not what she said nope sorry
let's roll into delete scenes the two
men shy okay
technical pause for volume and we are
the two man shines as a faded Captain
Kirk tide would be a direct threat to
Lou Ferrigno for convention autograph
deals and the late great Alan Rickman
he's so good as a Spock to Tim's Kirk
where is he al Borland to Tim's Tim does
that make bones Wilson who does that
make JT t what an insane collection of
talent
starring captain juror lon melons
he played Richard the third there were
five curtain calls in the middle Tony
and fans like you Space Jam Star Tours
Star Trek the meta picture reality TV
the movie mm-hmm Tropic Thunder in space
a lot yeah yeah all right the cool
premise and all but if aliens ever
actually came to earth because they
thought Tim Allen's movie was real
they're screwed if they're expected
Santa yeah yeah that's not gonna work
that's not gonna work at all yeah do we
have what you gotta do that oh no I just
these are my notes from Galaxy Quest cuz
I watched it so long ago I didn't
actually look at before the documentary
release a long time so we wrote this
like months ago yeah not just for the
release it was for like the comic-con
release right yeah yeah I've also got
mad senioritis right
we've literally been talking for like
for I want to go see Santa screen oh
yeah he's Tim Allen Santa stuff he's
sweet to Milan he is sweet sweet sweet
melons let's not call it Tim Allen sweet
well yeah let's plan for the audience
instead of a butthole um look there are
some words you can say them but when
people react to you saying them you
can't get mad about it
fair enough don't get mad if you you
know just no one has any questions
you're all just complimenting us so
thank you I appreciate you I like seeing
Meg down nice hat is it real just what a
date a Dom okay let's give a clue for
next week next week is oh go ahead I was
turning member what we were doing Oh pew
pew pew pew
oh and we're done
you